we are out of our homes mostly and back
on the road so let's discuss types of
injuries that can occur in low-speed car
crashes
with chris burke of the patriot law firm
welcome back chris thank you for having
me rocky always
always good to have you um so let's talk
about something that something new that
might interest our viewers out there
yeah actually you know what uh we've
seen an uptick recently with more cars
on the road
um people getting back to work due to
the governor uh allowing people to
go back to their jobs we've seen an
uptick in car crashes around the valley
and what kind of crashes are you seeing
mostly everything actually you know we
have always have some in the highway
main thoroughfares but even in
neighborhoods we've seen them too
sometimes we don't have a lot of speed
sometimes but those happen
and one question i've always wanted to
know and i know a lot of viewers want to
know too
do people really get injured in those
minor car crashes in neighborhoods or
well you know when i first started i i
was a little
skeptical as well but now that i've had
conversations
uh many conversations with folks that
are biomechanical experts phds people
that study the science the physics
they are telling us some interesting
things about how people can get hurt
their neck and back
uh due to these low speed crashes i
wonder what happens
in the science or the physics of that
but how does that actually correlate to
the crash
like what happened well think about it
right even a small car like a toyota
prius right and people think that's kind
of a small car
right it's a 3 000 pound machine so if
it's hitting you
from the rear going even you know five
seven miles an hour something like that
i mean that physics the science the
force gets transferred
into your vehicle and you know your you
the human body is not made like a
vehicle it's going to absorb some of
that but not all of it
right and what should people do if they
if they get into these crashes
well i mean obviously number one is they
need to make sure that they call the
police call the authorities
um get this documented and then number
two make sure you have a
uh experienced personal injury attorney
to help you if you are injured all right
there it is hurt by a drug better call
burke okay call them at the patriot law
firm 702
620 or visit them at their website
fightforthelittleguy.com